I think you might enjoy some of the clips
I'm going to play for you here sort of in
the way that I enjoy horrible things, which
I actually don't.
So this is going to be pretty horrifying.
We talked yesterday at the end of the show
about schools reopening or not.
And Donald Trump and Mike Pence's desire to
see schools open for what are what are effectively
political reasons.
Trump believes schools are being kept closed
in order to hurt him politically.
Now, that's not true.
But the fact that he perceives it as political
means that forcing them to reopen is also
political.
In other words, if keeping them closed hurts
him politically, opening them, he believes,
helps him politically.
Donald Trump tweeted two days ago in Germany,
Denmark, Norway, Sweden and many other countries,
schools are open with no problems.
The Dems think it would be bad for them politically
if U.S. schools open before the November election,
but is important for the families and for
the children and families may cut off of funding,
if not open.
Now, Trump is saying we want to be like Europe.
We want to do what Europe is doing.
But the reason Sweden is not doing so well,
but Germany, Denmark and Norway, the reason
they're doing well is because they handled
the virus completely differently.
If you want to be doing what Europe is doing
with schools, then you should have handled
corona virus the way those countries handled
that from the beginning.
But that's not really the focus today.
What we know today is that cases are up.
Deaths are up.
Summer camps have around the country, in Arkansas,
Missouri, other places have had to close because
coronavirus outbreaks have spread among the
children.
And yet Donald Trump and Mike Pence want schools
open, period.
Trump and Pence on Wednesday at different
events.
Both were asked about opening schools and
they were asked really specific questions
about what are the protocols, how do you ensure
safety?
And their mouths moved.
And a ton of stuff came out of their mouths,
but they were completely unable or unwilling
to articulate just exactly how you open schools
safely.
So let's look at some of these videos.
Let's start with Mike Pence.
Pence was asked, what exactly is the plan
to open schools safely?
Pence spoke for about 90 seconds and he didn't
answer the question.
I'm going to play the full answer for you
because I want you to see that he says nothing
about the question that was asked.
You're going to hear the question or actually
begin to skip it.
So you're not going to hear the question.
We're gonna go right to Mike Pence's answer
and notice how Pence doesn't state anything
that would count as an answer to the question.
Well, the plan is to continue to do what we've
done from the very beginning.
As you heard again this morning, we're we're,
I believe, 39 million tests that have been
performed all across this country.
You heard Admiral Geraud describe the extraordinary
commitment in just one community alone.
And what we've conveyed to governors is whatever
support they need to get kids back to school,
we're going to make sure that they have to
make sure that they have the testing resources.
We're currently educating states on the possibility
and working with commercial labs.
The possibility was called pooling so that
literally there could be one test run on,
say, 10 samples.
And there are particular universities that
already have built into their plans.
The idea of testing all of their students
at the beginning of the academic year and
then doing surveillance testing.
But we've made it very clear whether it's
testing, whether it's personal protective
equipment or other resources that we stand
ready to provide those resources to the states.
And and we reiterated that once again to the
governors.
But the good news is, because of the historic
mobilization that President Trump initiated,
we literally have hundreds of millions of
supplies of personal protective equipment,
59000 ventilators in the strategic national
stockpile.
Testing is scaling all across America.
And we know that come the school year, we'll
be ready to meet those needs.
So let's analyze it and go through it up.
Penn says we're going to do what we've done
from the beginning.
Well, you failed.
That has failed.
What you've done from the beginning is one
of the worst Korona response coronavirus responses
in the world.
Trump Pence says we've tested 39 million people
over a five month period.
Great.
It's not an answer to how do you open schools
safely.
Penn says we will give them the support they
need.
They're not asking for support.
They're saying it's not safe for you to decide
that they have to open.
And by the way, they failed to give states
the support they needed on testing.
So why would we trust them now that they're
going to give schools the support that they
need?
He says, we're looking at pool testing.
OK.
I mean, it's not really an answer to the question.
He says some universities will test their
students.
OK.
He says we'll send schools PPE if they want
it now and then.
He says Trump did a historic mobilization.
That's a meaning.
Claim it's untrue.
It was a historically bad mobilization, and
then Pence also mentions we have ventilators.
There is not an answer there because they
don't know how to open schools safely.
They don't care if schools open safely.
They want schools open in late August, early
September, with the hope that the that it
won't implode so quickly that they will get
a political benefit going into the November
election.
That's all they care about.
Now, CNN's Caitlin Collins had a good question
for Pence.
If if you insist that these are decisions
to be made locally by schools.
Why is Donald Trump pressuring them to open?
And of course, Mike Pence is completely flummoxed
by the question.
You're describing it as a local decision.
So should it be up to them to decide if they
can safely reopen or not?
The president saying he's going to pressure
them to do so.
Well, I look, we're going to respect those
unique communities that may have challenges
of rising cases or rising positivity.
And but I think you look at the nation as
a whole for the president of the United States
has made clear as he thinks, as we reopen
America, we need to reopen America's schools.
So I think you see where where that one is
going.
If a community is unique, they get to decide.
Pence says, I guess otherwise Trump decides
or something like that.
And then Pence also says, look at the nation
as a whole.
We had another single day, new case record.
We had multiple single day new case records
this week.
That's the nation as a whole.
In fact, if you want to make a case for safe
reopening, you should say, let's not look
at the nation as a whole, because places like
Florida and Texas and Arizona and California
and Oklahoma, where cases are spiking like
crazy.
They shouldn't open.
Maybe you could make the case that in states
that have really crushed the curve and even
those states, I'm worried, are going to start
seeing cases now as the numbers go nationally,
go so high, maybe you make the case that you
could take the states that are doing really
well, maybe even the counties that are doing
really well and look at reopening there.
But when Pence says, look at the nation as
a whole, the nation as a whole is setting
new records for cases.
And then Pence also says we also push to reopen
churches as if that's some kind of justification
for opening schools.
Opening churches was a disaster.
And in fact, many churches have been spreader
events, spreading spreader locations, clusters.
And that's a very bad idea.
Now then it's Trump.
Trump just says we have to do it and everybody
wants it.
Mike Pence pretends to give an answer, even
though he doesn't.
Trump doesn't even pretend.
Trump just says we just have to do it.
Everybody wants to open.
So we want to reopen the schools.
Everybody wants it.
The moms wanted.
The dads wanted.
The kids want it.
It's time to do it.
You know, our mortality rate is right now
at a level that people don't talk about, but
it's down ten fold, ten fold.
So you look at deaths are way down from this
horrible jhana virus.
And it's a disgrace that it happened.
Shouldn't have happened, but it did.
And the economy is coming back and it's coming
back strongly.
Jobs are setting records.
For two months ago, they set the record and
then again, almost five million new jobs last
month, which is a record.
And it broke our last record of a month before.
So the numbers are happening much faster than
anybody anticipated.
The stock market.
Nasdaq just hit another record today.
And the markets generally are just really
a very small amount below where they were
at the height of the market when we first
had to do this about four and a half, five
months ago.
Just meaningless meandering, free association,
rambling of sorts, cites no evidence that
everybody wants.
It says the mortality rate is low.
Remember, our death rate per capita is the
ninth highest in the world.
Out of more than 200 countries and territories,
he says, there are job records.
He talks about the Nasdaq or as he pronounces
at the Nasdaq.
And so between Mike Pence and Donald Trump
over the last 48 hours, a lot of bluster about
we've got to open schools.
Everybody wants the schools open.
It's all going to be safe.
No explanation of how and why it's safe, how
they know it's safe, how safety would be maintained.
What would I mean?
Listen, another important question is, if
these were serious people who had a plan for
how to safely open, then I would move to the
question of what data would say we have to
reclose.
In other words, would it be a certain number
of cases among students?
What if a teacher gets a case?
What if there's a parent at home with a case?
Is it case growth rate or absolute numbers?
What would be the metrics where you would
say we're going to do it, but we're going
to shut it down if X or Y?
I mean, it just it's I'm acting like these
are serious people and that's that that that's
the problem.
Last thing I get the importance of opening
schools.
A lot of parents can't work if the kids aren't
in school.
This is huge economically.
It's gonna be worse economically if you open
schools and the kids get the virus and the
teachers get the virus and the parents get
the vote, that will be much worse economically.
Tuesday, 8:00 p.m. David Pakman show chess
tournament.
Register for free at David Pakman dot com
slash chess.
And remember to get our daily audio podcast
on iTunes, Stitcher, Spotify, or whatever
your favorite podcasting app is.